we'd love to get to our next story um
from right here in our audience it's
time for what's your good news
so
it's our new segment and we're kicking
it off today and getting the scoop from
courtney mcwilliams all the way from new
orleans she's right here hello courtney
hi girl i'm so happy to be here oh my
god gabano say hi who is this cutie
patootie this is gabana
i love like how proper
yeah look at that face she's just like
okay
yeah
oh my god she's so cute now courtney
what is your good news today i own a
merry meg's doggy retreat in new orleans
louisiana and we're louisiana's first
black owned doggy daycare
and you know we were just talking more
people got pets during the pandemic than
ever so people need your help what can
they get at mary max oh a whole lot of
stuff um
we offer doggy daycare roaming boarding
and starting this week we'll be selling
our
conditioner and shampoo
do you do any training also
that part
i actually
created a course
that was supposed to start
tuesday after labor day for the doggy
day care for the doggy daycare the dogs
that's um in daycare yeah which include
enrichment activities and learning a
trick every month
so now i'm trying to figure out how to
get it online
because i'm not sure when we'll be able
to go back home right right how is your
how is everything in new orleans will
you tell us about it
new orleans is
very resilient um
they're very resilient like we're
stronger than ever the community is
pulling together the mayor is awesome
um
some houses
are damaged by wind we didn't get any
water that much
my house is perfectly fine right now
which is good as well as my business
i've even been thinking about going back
to do something for the first responders
to help them out because
they have to work so many days on and so
many days off and they also need doggy
day care while they're working so i may
be traveling back home and opening back
up this weekend
you know
i i really like to ask life advice um
from you
how do you get outside of yourself and
wake up in the morning and say i'm going
to take care of someone else today
what's something that maybe we could all
do just one small thing one piece of
advice that we could learn from you
courtney
gratitude
gratitude i wake up every morning and i
do a gratitude journal
and i always ask
what can i do to make somebody else's
day better
and did you have something in your life
happen that makes you ask that question
why do you ask that question
so my background is in social work
and i spent many years practicing social
work and i've actually included social
work and incorporated it into my doggy
day care and so
that background
is the driving force of me asking what
can i do to help make someone's day
better
well
i'm just so glad you are in the world
being the first black owned business for
doggy daycare and grooming in
louisiana what an impressive incredible
thing
and that you're just the person that you
are and thank you for reminding me
um to keep up with my gratitude journal
and to look at life in the world because
i want to be a good person and it's so
fun on a job like this or in a show like
this that we can reach out and ask
advice and questions and get new ideas
on how to take care of each other
yeah so thank you courtney thank you for
having us
thank you
and thanks for kicking off our new
segment we'll be right back
[Music]
you